mein name ist julian back to bed ersetzt
worden
du willst ein wort der kirchen servus
erst kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video max es an meiner seite
so wie sie sein sollte wie seine mutter
die leute wollen es die leute kriegen
smart und heute gibt den tipp schon
gesehen eine trainer to love
unsympathisch tv edition
das heißt wir gehen auf der compilation
von den lustigen momenten von sascha
hellinger und versuchen nicht zu lachen
dabei wäre natürlich gewesen wenn es
heute mit dabei gewesen wäre aber der
antwortet mir leider nicht auf meine
insta nachrichten
tja verkackt leute ja wir fangen die
hand es wird ganz normal sein so epische
musik ich laufe auch die bühne
epische musik läuft noch weiter dann
reichen ein worüber lacht und sagt so
kenne ich mich doch mal ein bisschen
davor jetzt schon sympathische frau und
ich werde halt ich habe mir überlegt ich
glaube einfach dezent in meinem vortrag
leihen weil ich fühlt sich die leute
wenn ich dieses verhalten die irgendwie
national kommen deswegen würde ich
einfach so anfangen so wird anfang also
ich will kämpfen
das ist patrick kaiser
[Gelächter]
über den film heute weiter mit dem video
und kölner innenstadt brachte dies so
zwei leute sich so weit kommt mir nicht
in den kopf geschossen wird wenn du mir
noch einmal dann habe ich es persönlich
zu dir nach hause hat nämlich so arg
auseinander dass wir ja was soll man
dazu sagen
die zuschauer lieben es nett mir immer
sympathisch
dazu bekennt es wird ich hoffe dass ich
hab's auch gar nicht gesagt stand die
mindestens zwei tage ich will auch wenig
gesagt hat man könnte jetzt muskeln
das ist vielleicht mit mindestens zwei
tage ich will mein ok kleinen wir kleine
fortschritte aber scheint was hast du
eben mit diesen alten land widmet ist
aber nur so müssten blogger nur eine von
diesen hilfen nicht die schilder immer
wo sie diese diese jahner nicht erzählt
man mit so einfach leer dann das hier
das feld gartenhäuser zu beginn steigen
wir ein mit jemandem der jetzt egal wie
ich habe mir gedacht zu beginn über dem
eigenen der eher unbedeutend mein name
ist und willkommen zu einer neuen folge
zuschauer und fans bei mein name ist was
haben sollen
mein name ist mein name ist julia du
willst
[Gelächter]
das könnten die das ende wirklich alter
was sagt ein bauer der seinen traktor
sucht wo ist mein traktor
das war es auch schon wieder von mir
liebe leute keinen dank fürs zuschauen
last auf dem video ist die ente mit von
in sceaux der erst mal ist das haben wir
die zehntelsekunde zu 50 liter davon ins
kleine videos du bist du im auto weg von
den videotipp ist so ein zuschauer ist
er da der fahrertür sowieso passiert
aber auch gelegentlich hab ich werde die
situation aber wachsen aber ich war
fahrertag sommer
das ist mitte dame aber ich bin da und
ich bin da was machst du denn hier ja
mehr zurück auf die letzten 5 678
vielleicht minuten habe ich aber
verkaufen weil ich jetzt bin und du hast
leider gewonnen kann ja nicht sein
ja stimmt ja heute mal ein kurzes
schnelles video weil ich leider nicht
mehr lage wenn wir einen tag sind
40 40 danke an master auf highlights in
innsbruck und dann sascha deren konto
wie immer ganz dreist geklaut haben max
in dem schreiben verlinkt